a view of Budapest from a taxi the
Hungarian capital is located on both
sides of the river Danube
more than 1.7 million people live in
Budapest one of them is Mariana buds are
who's been a taxi driver in the city for
more than 20 years
she was just nine years old when she
decided that being a cabbie would be her
dream job someday
driving the taxi in Budapest is a
fascinating thing you can show r and you
can be really proud the city's beautiful
you meet all kinds of people from around
the world and you can be also little bit
like helping them guiding them being a
personal assistant so driving a taxi is
not only means that you are driving a
car from point A to point B is a little
bit more I like it some passengers hire
Mariana bots are as a tour guide and as
a cabbie she knows all the city's hidden
gems look on the left this is my
favorite place on earth this is matthias
church and the fisherman's bastion and
this is one of those porns where you can
see past side in total view so i often
driving foreign guys here to let them
see pesticides from here
the danube panorama was declared a
unesco world heritage site in 1987 as
was the eight hundred year old castle
district the matthias church is where
the austrian emperors were once crowned
as kings of hungary buddha castle the
city's landmark houses the hungarian
national gallery among other treasures
a total of nine bridges span the Danube
as it winds its way through Budapest the
chain bridge was the first to link the
formerly separate cities of Buda and
pest nearby at the Hungarian State Opera
Mariana buds are picked up her most
famous passenger
the most famous people I have ever
driven she was also undressed she was
here too short a statistical movie in
our house and I've taken her and her
colleagues to the Gallup bath and later
they invited me to a restaurant here
around the corner which is a very very
special restaurant since the waiter or
the waitress continued an opera song why
they are serving your dinner it was a
really nice experience for me the first
taxi company in Budapest started in 1913
it had 25 cabs in its fleet the first
ever in Hungary in the 1930s Budapest
became the first city in the world where
you could order a cab by phone today
some 6,000 taxis ply their trade on the
city streets more than 1 million people
take a cab each month
compared with other European cities a
taxi and Budapest is relatively
inexpensive every taxi in Budapest has
to has the same price the same price on
kilometers same price on time and same
price on a base which is like 80 50 cent
at the moment a kilometer when evening
comes Budapest seventh District comes to
life at the end of the 1990s this is
where the first ruin pubs opened in
abandoned buildings now there are more
than 25 of them
this is a really famous pub in the area
which is famous from the wrong pops if
you want to do ads in Budapest at night
this can be a good choice because these
pups around us are fantastic and also
affordable Mariana bots are used to
drive mostly at night but she's changed
her working hours now after a long work
day she sets off for home through
nighttime Budapest
you